here's the thing i'm such a fan of the
genre
of of horror of social thriller sci-fi
whatever you want to call it
um but it has been frustrating for me as
an artist because the roles you're
offered as a black woman are so
dismissive and and not really central to
the plot
i know we were all meant to
go through trials and tribulations
why this world is haunting
[Music]
you have played so many amazing women
throughout your career but i feel like
lettie lewis is about to jump
to the top from her absolute
fearlessness to that amazing wardrobe um
what does this character mean to you
and and what do you hope that women who
are watching her take away from her
yeah i mean letty it was such a
privilege to
approach letting i mean honestly i
approached it in a very sacred way
um she's so buoyant right um
and yet she's also a woman who who
struggles with certain
um the lineage of trauma that she's
inherited from
her mother um but to me i know letty
you know like i i know her she's my
grandmother i
i i never met my grandmother but when i
approached the character i thought of my
grandmother a lot
she was nicknamed showtime and she was
you know this woman who really just
wouldn't let
folks in the 1950s or 60s erase her
you know she she fought to maintain her
dignity which was such a radical act
to me growing up you know hearing these
stories there's something here
just trying to get out
i love that you had recently said that
you were not interested in playing the
girl on
page 33 in the horror movie who gets
killed
and now here you are playing the lead in
this groundbreaking series
do you feel like you're helping to
redefine the term scream queen
you're the first person to ask that i
mean here's the thing i'm such a fan of
the genre
of of horror of social thriller sci-fi
whatever you want to call it um
but it it has been frustrating for me as
an artist because the roles you're
offered as a black woman are so
dismissive and and not really central to
the plot
and it's just incredibly exciting to
have voices
you know coming along like misha green
like a jordan peel
um you know in which
they're flipping this classical genre on
its head deconstructing it and centering
you know black voices in it because
we've been shut out for so long
many people are praising lovecraft
country for its
timeliness but i know that you
personally have said it's a bit
exhausting
that we are in 2020 and we're still
needing to acknowledge the themes of
combating white supremacy
so what do you feel like this series is
going to contribute to that conversation
yeah i mean i think um i mean look it
goes back to
what nina simone says when she talks
about the duty of the artist
is to reflect the times it is very
timely however
for me yeah i i asked the question when
would this not
have been timely you know unfortunately
we're still
um dealing with the systemic racism that
our nation was built upon we've yet to
dismantle it we've yet to heal it we've
yet to fully confront it
but not just is the story timely it's
also deeply personal
okay like i i can relate to the feeling
of displacement that letty feels
you know i can relate to the isolation
you feel when you are the only black
family
in an all-white neighborhood you know a
fish was put on my family's lawn when i
was young
the day of the million man march you
know i know what it's like
to to have that fear of driving while
black when a police car
rolls up beside you um so it's personal
these stories we're telling but my hope
is that
you know look we're fighting two
pandemics right now okay
um covet and systemic racism and i i
hope that
the conversations just continue in that
lovecraft country
it's just a part of the conversation
that we're already having
i'm calling this the weekend of journey
because not only is do we have lovecraft
country we have birds of prey
coming to hbo max i know it's so cool
right
isn't this fun it's just like the
sleepover we should order pizza
make cosmos harley okay and i don't know
if you saw but there was recently like
an
online twitter buzz where people really
really want a black canary solo
series on hbo max like what's the status
of you suiting up again
oh my gosh i did see the love from that
it meant so much
i mean listen
i i i'm not you gotta ask the suits
i mean it's not up to me you know i love
black canary come on who won
any person would die to play the
character
so i'm no different in having stepped
into
the character with words of prey i had
so much fun and
just love just fell in love with with
her
and the world and the potential
um so yes i would do it again if
asked if ass so you know it but it's not
up to me it's about my pay grade
[Music]
okay